97 year old sandy cortman is given the
all-clear to jump
applause is the world war two veteran
land safely he was just 22 when he
parachuted onto the same drop zone in
September 1944 operation Market Garden
was one of the most significant and
ill-fated parachute drops of world war
ii general Montgomery he his idea
dropping paratroopers the male gained no
sleep he was wrong they didn't Italy
their studio and sin I feel like crap
men coming Jesus
Prince Charles the colonel-in-chief of
the parachute regiment alongside
Netherlands Princess Beatrix met the
veterans as they took their place for
the memorial service Minister for
defence people and veterans Johnny
Mercer also made the jump with the Red
Devils it's hugely important I think you
know we can be pretty pretty quick to
sort of move on from our past sometimes
and days like today it shows you how
important it is to remember and I think
you know just it's quite mind-blowing
what these guys did 75 years ago today
operation Market Garden sought 35,000
British American and Polish troops
parachute behind German lines in a bid
to open up an attack route for Allied
forces more than 1,500 Commonwealth
soldiers were killed six and a half
thousand were captured today's parachute
jumps are part of a host of
commemorative events this week to mark
the 75th anniversary of the Battle of
Arnhem in recognition of the sacrifice
made to help liberate the Netherlands
Ashleigh Blake Sky News